la función continua efe está definida en
el intervalo menos 4 menor o igual que x
menor o igual que 3 la gráfica de f
consiste en dos cuartos de círculo y un
segmento de línea estos son nuestros
cuartos de círculo y este es un segmento
de línea como se muestra en la siguiente
figura en la figura que les acabo de
mostrar bueno sea gtx igual a 2 x más la
integral de 0 a x df de tdt esta función
que de x parece ser que va a ser muy
interesante bueno vamos a resolver el
inciso a encuentre g de menos 3 entonces
queda menos 3 es igual como está
definida g bueno que está definida como
2 veces x o sea 2 x menos tres más la
integral de 0 a x pero x vale menos 3
entonces es la integral de cero menos
tres de mi función
efe dt de t bien en la primera parte
está muy sencilla de hacer 2 x menos 3
es menos 6 entonces
menos 6 más la integral de 0 a menos 3
df de tdt y esto esencialmente quiere
decir que queremos el área que está bajo
mi función
efe dt de 0 a menos 3 recuerden que mi
integral definida me habla de un área
abajo en la curva abajo mi función de fx
delimitada por el eje de las x sin
embargo hay que tener cuidado no hay que
caer en la trampa porque esta área que
yo tengo aquí esta de aquí
es la integral de de menos tres a cero
de f de tdt esta área que yo tengo aquí
es integral de menos tres a cero de fp
de t porque recuerden que siempre el
número menor tenía que ir abajo de la
integral y el número mayor tenía que ir
arriba de la integral y aquí tengo una
integral de cero a menos 3 lo tengo como
que volteado invertido los índices de la
integral por lo tanto voy a cambiarlo
como se cambia pues esto es lo mismo que
menos seis menos menos la integral de
menos tres a cero de f
dt cuando yo quiero cambiar los índices
de integración lo que necesita ponerle
es un signo de menos antes de la
integral y ahora si la integral de menos
tres a cero df de tdt es esta área que
yo tengo coloreada y si se dan cuenta y
tienen un poco de idea de geometría es
un cuarto de un círculo que de hecho
tiene un radio igual a 3 tenemos tres
unidades de menos tres a cero
y si esta área es un cuarto del área de
un círculo cuyo radio tiene tres
unidades entonces quién va a ser pues el
círculo completo tendría pi o radio al
cuadrado o sea y por tres al cuadrado o
sea en 9 pi
pero como solamente queremos un cuarto
de círculo hay que dividirlo entre
cuatro y bien ya tenemos por fin el
resultado o la respuesta de mi primera
parte del inciso a de este problema es
decir menos seis menos nueve entre
cuatro ahora sí vamos a la segunda parte
en la segunda parte nos piden que
encontremos ag prima de x ya tenemos la
primera parte la primera parte queda que
de menos 3 que es menos 6 + 9 y entre 4
y ahora me piden encontrar que prima de
x bien prima de x pero entonces hay que
derivar de x pero detrás de gx primero
es la derivada de 2 x que es 2
estoy muy sencillo y después quiero la
derivada de la integral de 0 a x df de
tdt pero por el teorema fundamental del
cálculo esto es simplemente efe
x el teorema fundamental del cálculo
está involucrado aquí y ya tenemos la
segunda respuesta por fin tenemos que
que prima de x es igual a dos más
fx perfecto y yo es lo que quiero ahora
para acabar este inciso es que prima
evaluado en menos tres que esto es 2 más
efe evaluado en menos 3 pero quién es
esto estos dos más
efe evaluado en menos 3 pero aquí en
este elevado al menos 3 nos damos cuenta
efe en menos 3 como es continua es
simple y sencillamente 0 se dan cuenta
es este punto que estaba aquí es 0 y
esto es 2 + 0 que es 2 y ya por fin
tenemos la tercera respuesta del primer
inciso de este problema y si se dan
cuenta y acabamos el primer inciso de
este problema ya tenemos sus tres partes
y de hecho lo más difícil o tal vez lo
más tramposo de este inciso fue evaluar
los límites de integración es decir que
la integral de menos tres a cero df de
tdt
al menos la integral de 0 a menos 3 d
efe de tdt